c'est pas la cerise sur le gâteau ça
arrive
vite parce que dans les 15 minutes elle
pénalité là-haut c'est bon tout le 15
je livre et j'arrive tout de suite
faut que je la livre vite parce que
après je peux me faire le
c'est où c'est là va vous me garder
là-bas il faut que je lisse oh merde
regardez ce que vous faites faire aussi
bah aidez-moi maintenant
non mais je vous demander et puis
il y a pas gros
voilà
[Musique]
attention monsieur
vous êtes pas délicat non plus
bon alors je vais le dire oh bordel
merde
parce que là je me fais virer là
on s'en fout on est jeune regardez hop
ça peut donner la maladie à quelqu'un
pardon
je me fasse virer c'est présentable ou
pas monsieur bon ça va ça prend la
blague vous croyez que c'est pas bien
vous en foutez
on la met pas on dirait une merguez ou
pas
on dirait quoi
c'est vous qui m'avez donné l'idée
monsieur du tout
ça
non mais c'est pas la solution au niveau
de la présentation
ça fait la blague ou pas
ok au niveau de la déco c'est pas
superbe
ça c'est présentable maintenant
j'ai tout fait tomber
vous seriez pas où je pourrais trouver
du travail
chez vous ça va pas être possible de
faire des amis qui ont un matelas rien
du tout quoi
5 francs la part laissez-vous tenter
c'est la dernière
c'est pas mal
voilà et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de Inna latitude abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce bleu